[Music]
we have e.t coming to our video
with my girl
that's something that you dream of yeah
charlie's angels come on it's the song
that solidified destiny's child as a
trio question tell me what you think
about me i bought my own diamonds and i
buy my own rings and only e.t was on set
[Music]
i got the opportunity of writing and
producing the song for the charlie's
angel soundtrack and it's a great song
it's all about women and independents
it's called independent women as a
matter of fact we're just excited and we
were very blessed to have the
opportunity to be the group to sing the
theme song
[Music]
we have our 70s soul train outfits
tina knows our style is designed and i'm
really excited about that beyonce's
other style inspiration for the video
the og charlie's angel i'm only 19
and i didn't see many episodes but i
have seen a couple episodes and the
ladies kicked but they were they were
cool and i definitely love fairfax and
in the wings i'm i'm jacking her style
[Music]
to have the success that we've had
within the past two years has been
unbelievable we're on tour with
christina aguilera right now and it's
been wonderful every night has been sold
out the fans have been great we've been
selling merchandising we've been
performing our new song which is cool
because it's not out yet and all of the
fans by the end of the song everybody's
hands are up so that's a good sign
i know we've had like four number one
singles hopefully this will be the fifth
and
i'm just blessed independent women did
go number one and was the first
chart-topping single for dc-3 destiny's
child has definitely been through
a lot as far as our members but we are
survivors and the group is now at its
best there's no need to add another
member which hall is angels now
[Music]
oh
[Music]